MICHAEL ANTON: Good evening.
My name is Michael Anton.
I am a lecturer
and research fellow
here at the Kirby Center, which
means that I have teaching
duties, among other things.
I taught a class Monday, I
taught a class last night.
Some of my students
are even here tonight,
and they shall withhold
further comment
until evening is over as to
the quality of instruction.
We have students.
Many of you are familiar
with the college's program
in Washington.
But for those of you who
aren't, just reiterate,
say, four year liberal
arts college in Michigan.
But every semester, a small
number, usually around 20,
take a semester and
come here as part
of their college experience.
They work an internship
somewhere in Washington.
That could be on the Hill,
it could be in a think tank,
could be in an executive
branch agency, a nonprofit.
And then they take all
their classes at night.
So imagine, have
a little sympathy,
if you work 9:00 to
5:00 and then you
got to drag yourself in here and
listen to me for three hours,
starting at 6 o'clock,
it's hard on them.
But they do very good
work, they work hard.
And they're an impressive
bunch, and you'll
be able to meet some
of them tonight.
And in fact, one of them will
be introducing our speaker.
I was sort of asked
to say something
about the topic
of our speaker, I
think because I served on
the National Security Council
for a time.
And it's presumed that I
know something about this.
Unfortunately, I don't really.
But I do have one
very small story.
I was a speechwriter for a
time on the National Security
Council back in the
Bush administration.
And I was the foreign policy
speechwriter for the president.
And the president, he had a sort
of a policy Interagency Working
Group that was to determine the
new space policy for the United
States.
And it went on for
many, many months.
And toward the end they
said, well, the president's
going to roll out
the space speech.
And I got assigned
the space speech,
so I got to go to the final I
don't know, five or so weeks
of meetings to figure this out.
And I remember asking,
when I was assigned
the speech, my boss,
I said, I'm supposed
to be the foreign policy guy.
But lately, you've been
giving me immigration,
you've been given me the
Patriot Act speeches,
you've just been
sort of piling it on.
And this is getting
a bit difficult.
What does this have to do
with my official duties?
And my boss said, well,
you know, space is foreign.
[LAUGHTER]
So I wrote the space speech.
Now, my mother
loved that speech.
She was very impressed by it.
She watched it on television
and called me later
to tell me how great it was.
It was not a hit at the time.
This would have been, I
think around January of 2004.
And it was widely ridiculed.
This was when President Bush
announced that we would go back
to the Moon, we would
eventually move onto Mars,
and things like that.
And people thought it was
an election year ploy.
And it wasn't a hit, and it was
famously the subject of comedy
skit on a show I can't quote
because this is a family
college.
But it's on YouTube, and
it was widely ridiculed.
And I think that's the way
it's most remembered today.
But fast forward a little bit.
So I was working in
a job in Manhattan,
and I got invited
at the last minute
to go out to a small dinner.
And I show up, and it's
one friend of mine,
a bunch people I don't know, and
one person whom I didn't know,
but I recognized.
And it was Neil deGrasse
Tyson, of all people.
The famous TV astronomer
and astrophysicist.
I don't know how it came up.
I don't think I volunteered.
He somehow dragged
out of me that yeah, I
wrote the space speech.
And I thought, here
it comes, right?
He's just going to beat
the heck out of me.
But actually he was
very nice about it.
He said that he had
consulted on the policy
and he thought the policy was
actually pretty sound with one
or two reservations.
And he remembered the
speech, and he gave me
a critique of it right there.
He said, these are the three
things you really screwed up.
But as for the rest of
it, it was pretty good.
And I thought, well,
it could be worse.
All right, now, the actual
introduction of our speaker
will come from, as
I said, a student.
One of the, we call him
the WHIP students, which
stands for Washington
Hillsdale Internship Program,
her name is Riley Arlihouse.
She is a junior at the
college where she's
studying politics and Spanish.
She's originally from
Missouri City, Texas.
And I'll have you know, she's
also the daughter of an Air
Force officer herself.
She's currently interning
at the Heritage Foundation
during her semester here.
Please welcome me in joining
Riley to introduce our speaker.
[APPLAUSE]
RILEY ARLIHOUSE: Good evening.
Thank you for coming.
Our speaker tonight
is Steven L. Kwast.
Steve Kwast is a retired
Air Force general
and former commander of the Air
Education and Training Command
at Joint Base San
Antonio Randolph.
A graduate of the
United States Air Force
Academy with a degree in
astronomical engineering,
he holds a master's
degree in public policy
from Harvard's Kennedy
School of Government.
He is a past president of the
Air Force's Air University
in Montgomery, Alabama,
and a former fighter
pilot with extensive combat
and command experience.
He is the author of the study
"Fast Space Leveraging Ultra
Low Cost Space Access for
21st Century Challenges."
And tonight he will be speaking
on the urgent need for a US
space force.
Please join me in
welcoming Steve Quast.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVEN QUAST: So Riley is
an example of our future.
And that's really what we're
going to be talking about.
But history does repeat itself.
So Michael, I have your speech.
And that's the one I'm
going to give tonight.
So you should probably
recognize it a bit.
But Riley, thank you.
And you truly are the future.
And that's why this is
such a happy conversation.
But it's also one
reason why it's
such an important conversation.
Because life has always been
a competition, ultimately
a competition of values.
And everything else is
wrapped around that.
But when we asked
this question about,
do we need a space force?
I'd like to unpack
that a little bit,
because it's important
to first start with why.
Why do we need a space force?
And once we understand
why we need a space force,
then we can talk about,
well, when do we need it,
and what should it do?
Critical elements of
this central question
we're going to
explore this evening,
and I'm looking forward
to your questions.
But one of the most
important points of thinking
is first understanding
what's going on around you.
What's happening?
What is the context here?
Why is this important?
And as a historian,
reflecting on the fact
that, throughout the
history of mankind,
at least everything we
can read and understand,
technology has always
changed world power.
Whether it was the
caveman that figured out
how to harness the power of fire
to keep his or her tribe warm
and survive the cold winters
and cook the food so they didn't
die from bacteria
and other things,
they had a competitive advantage
and their DNA survived.
Their values survived.
To the invention of the
airplane, the nuclear weapon,
you take a look at
any technology that
has been optimized by a
certain tribe, civilization,
it can become a tool of national
power that changes world power.
Space is going to change world
power because of the power
of space and what it can do.
And we're going to explore
that a little bit tonight.
But it's also a story of
human nature and culture.
As a missionary kid growing
up in a tribal African area,
I can tell you that
world paradigms clash,
and they can trap a civilization
into a certain world paradigm.
And this human
nature will not only
embrace something
that helps them,
but it also will
reject anything new.
And this idea of a
space force is very new,
and is experiencing the same.
But this is not new in time.
A small island
nation like England
could dominate the world economy
and become the most powerful
military, economic,
and political force
on planet Earth as a
small island nation,
because they optimized the
development of deep sea
navigation and sail
and ships and the Navy.
But the story of rejecting
new and holding and clinging
to the paradigms of the past
is why no civilization has ever
lasted forever.
And values are trumped
by other values
when another
civilization figures out
a way of finding a
competitive advantage.
And in England, probably
the most famous story
is World War I. In
1914, the English
were hungry to go to war with
Germany, because they were
certain that their
superior tactics,
and the Napoleonic method of
warfare that they had refined
to a perfect art, that
had dominated the globe,
would dominate once again.
And even though there were
historians and technologists
and strategists that
pointed out the machine
gun and the development
of poison gas,
the leadership said, we
don't have time for that.
The courage, the nobility,
and the aggressiveness
of our fighters were overcome.
Our single rifles will just
overwhelm that machine gun
nest.
And we'll just hold our
breath and run through the gas
and fight on the other side.
And after England lost an
entire generation of Englishmen,
they turned to their most
respected intellect, Dr.
Fisher, and asked
the question, why did
we lose an entire generation?
And he said, you
didn't lose because you
had inferior technology.
You had the best
technology on planet Earth.
It wasn't your tactics,
your tactics were perfect.
You lost an entire
generation because of a lack
of vision and strategy.
Sun Tzu in The Art of
War talks about this.
It's not about the technology,
it's about the strategy.
And so here we sit today.
Back in that day,
those historians
and the technologists brought
to the leadership of England
this counsel that they needed
to invest in the machine
gun and gas, or
at least find ways
of fighting through those,
because those would change
the character of war.
And they ignored it,
saying we've got time.
We've been the best, so we
will be the best, projecting
the past into the future.
We do the same today.
And this community
in America brought
the technologies
that are emerging,
and the strategies that are
emerging internationally
and domestically to
this administration.
And this administration
said, build a space force.
But the reason space
is so powerful is not
that it just has a military
application like a machine gun.
It's because it will transform
the four major engines
of economic growth that
have been consistent
throughout mankind.
Transportation, information,
manufacturing, and probably
most important, the ability
to deliver that transportation
and information with energy.
Energy, the seed corn
of all development,
all growth, all
survival, energy.
So energy, transportation,
information,
and manufacturing--
these are the things
that change humanity,
that will change world power.
And they are descending upon us
in ways that are very unique.
The technology is on the
engineering benches today.
But most Americans
and most in Congress
have not had time to really look
deeply at what's going on here.
But I've had the benefit of 33
years of studying and becoming
friends with these engineers
and these scientists.
This technology
can be built today
with technology that is not
developmental to deliver
any human being from any
place on planet Earth
to any other place
in less than an hour,
to deliver Wi-Fi from
space, where you never
need a cell tower to connect.
To deliver energy from
space where you never
have to plug your phone
in and it trickle charges,
and you can use that
energy over time.
It can be applied
to cars, to houses.
The technology of
Edison and Tesla
that we live with in our energy
environment, our paradigm
today, is expensive, it's
dangerous, and it's wasteful.
Plug it into the wall.
But yep, that's what
we all do, because we
are used to paradigms.
The power of space will
change world power forever.
And it doesn't have to be
a big country to do it.
It can be a small island
country, let's say,
New Zealand.
Because the technology,
if optimized,
can change world power.
And there's nothing you can do
if you don't have that power.
The nature of power,
you either have it
and your values rule,
or you do not have it
and you must submit.
We see that play out again
and again in history,
and it's playing out now.
But we get trapped.
Here in America, for example,
three times in the last hundred
years, we have
failed to optimize
the technologies that were
coming about, to our own peril.
In 1920, the country
turned to General Pershing
and General MacArthur.
That's the Father MacArthur, the
two Medal of Honor recipients,
father and son.
In 1920, they asked
them the question,
should the aeroplane be
developed independently?
Should the tank
and mechanization
be developed independently?
And they said, absolutely not.
And they dictated that
the airplane and the tank
must be developed
by the infantry,
because the infantry
is the main event.
The Signal Corps
And that fatal decision by the
most respected and heralded
heroes of the age cost thousands
of lives in World War II,
because the development of
the airplane and the tank
were insufficient
for the competition.
And at that time,
it was Germany.
We lost more airmen in the
European theater than all
of the Marines in World War II.
And the number of young
men we intentionally
had to slaughter in the Sherman
tank, which its shell would
bounce off the Panzer
and the Tiger Tank,
we had to literally
and knowingly sacrifice
an entire frontal attack to be
eviscerated by the German tank
lines to get enough Shermans
around the back, which
at close range from
behind, was the only way
to kill a Panzer or a
Tiger with a Sherman tank.
And that's because
the people developing
the tank and the airplane,
every extra dollar
was spent on the infantry
and a better gun,
because that was the main event.
The tank was not
meant as a main event,
it was meant to
protect the infantry.
The airplane was
not the main event,
it was to spot troops
for the Signal Corps.
It was not intended by anybody.
The biggest trap of
culture is mindset.
And we get trapped in a
mindset like electricity,
that it has to be that way.
Our children will be
plugging into a wall
when the technology does
not need to be that way.
But here's why space is
so much more powerful
and why this question of the
Space Force is so important.
It's because we have
competition today.
If the development of space
to do these things that I just
described to you transform
the transportation economy
to be able to deliver anybody
anywhere on planet Earth
in less than an hour, transform
the energy market where
everybody can trickle charge
their batteries and capacitors
to power anything on
planet Earth from anywhere
without any power
lines, any power plants,
transform information where
you can get information
about what's going
on around you,
and you don't need to be near
a city or near a cell tower,
because you're delivering it
from a network in space that
can deliver it to
every human being.
And then we can
manufacture things
in space using the
vacuum and zero g,
to not only do
research medically,
but to build facilities
and structures in ways
we could have never
done before, and deliver
them as light as
a feather anywhere
on planet Earth for pennies on
the dollar of transportation
costs in a linear sea, land,
and air friction environment.
And whenever humanity has a
new marketplace like this,
if there is not some
guardian force that
brings predictability to
that economic marketplace,
violence ensues.
Pirates, thieves,
and thugs steal
what good men and women build.
And it's just a part
of human nature,
and that will not change.
So as we look to
these new markets
and we see Elon Musk
building a starship that
will be able to
launch from anywhere
and go anywhere in
less than an hour,
with massive volume and
weight, and he throws up
12,000 satellites that will
bring you Wi-Fi from space
where you will laugh
at your descendants,
or your fathers and mothers
that had to rely on cell towers,
or see the little circle of
death waiting for signal,
they will laugh
and scoff at that.
They will laugh
and scoff that you
had to put fuel into your tank
in your car or plug into a wall
because your phone was running
out of juice in the airports.
The lines waiting for
the outlet are no more.
We get trapped in
these paradigms.
But yet, just like
Germany was competition
for the airplane, the tank,
and the nuclear weapon,
that we eventually
won but at great cost,
China is our competition.
Russia is our competition.
They see the power of the
economy of space in these four
sectors, and they are
rushing to that future.
And there is no guardian
force in America.
But there is in China.
China has already
built the organization
and has the strategy
and the doctrine
and the technology and the
builders for their guardian
force of space.
They are building
a navy in space
with the equivalent of
battleships and destroyers
that will be able to maneuver
and kill and communicate
with dominance.
And we are not.
Now, this analogy might
help clarify the picture,
going back to my original
comment of what's
really going on here?
The competition is not about
making better satellites,
or even having a
constellation of satellites.
When you see China on
the far side of the moon,
mapping today the
minerals and the resources
so that they can eventually
have infrastructure
to build and 3D print
and have a manufacturing
industry in space,
what you are watching
is the equivalent of us sitting
here on our continental United
States--
let's say we're in Miami.
And we're looking out
over the wide open ocean.
That ocean is deep space.
The orbit around the
Earth is the shoreline
where the waves are crashing.
The deep water is space.
And there is a continent
out there three times
the size of Africa.
That's the Moon.
And nobody lives there.
It's only three days away.
It has massive
amounts of everything
that Mother Earth has.
To include water
on the south pole
and the craters greater than the
Great Lakes, as far as volume.
And China is racing with
ships on that open ocean,
to that great,
open, desolate place
that can be turned into
resources and blessing
for a marketplace.
And they're doing it not
just to get the resources,
but to tap into the trillion
dollar markets on planet Earth.
Imagine what you could do
if you could sell technology
to somebody from China
and deliver Wi-Fi.
And once you've built the
infrastructure in space,
you can deliver it for pennies.
Electricity, where your
satellite dish doesn't just
get DirecTV now,
it gets energy that
supplies your Chinese
batteries and capacitors
as they're building.
To get radio waves
from space that
give you that energy over time.
They will tap into those
trillion dollar markets
as they have in the past,
as we have in the past,
and fund their ecosystem, their
economy, their marketplace
in cislunar space,
which is basically
the distance between the
Earth and the Moon and beyond.
And we, as an American society,
we are sitting on Miami Beach
sipping our piña colada,
looking out at the waves.
And as we are
watching China build
this Navy, with battleships
and destroyers going out
into the open oceans, and off
to this continent three times
the size of Africa, we are
building buoys and lighthouses,
which are the satellites,
that can see and hear
what's going on, but can't do
a darn thing about that rover
on the backside of the moon,
the far side of the moon.
That if we were to
try to go there,
they could shoot us down.
And speed matters.
Speed matters because whoever
gets to the new market
sets the values for that market.
And we could either
have the market
with the values of
our constitution,
where every human
being is created equal
and loved equally by
God and their parents
and their brothers and sisters,
and that respect is manifested
in the rights of an individual
to vote, to own land,
to bear arms, all the things
the Constitution gives us.
Or we can have the values
that we see manifest in China,
Hong Kong, the Uyghurs.
You pick your example of
subordination and crushing
religion and human
rights and human dignity
and human liberty.
But America is such a
good-hearted country,
we oftentimes are deceived by
the nature of China's strategy.
Their strategy is not to
make better satellites.
Their strategy is to build
an economy before we do.
Because if you get there
first, they will be able to,
with a constellation
in space, see and kill
anything that flies
above the trees.
The blood and treasure required
to get back to that high ground
if we are not there
first will pale
in comparison to World
War II and World War I
in ways that only those
that study this technology
and its power can know.
Because China has met--
for 30 years, they have
met every single milestone
of their space program.
And in the next 10
years, they will
have solar and nuclear power
generation space stations
on orbit.
They broadcast that they will
be used for peaceful purposes,
that those radio waves
will bring energy
to anybody on planet Earth
without the need for power
lines or power plants.
But in a millisecond,
that dominance
of the electromagnetic
spectrum can
be directed energy that could
paralyze any part of our power
grid and freeze any
military might that America
builds on the spot.
Every carrier battle fleet
is a cork in the water.
Every fleet of fighters
is dead on the ramp,
can't even turn the wheel
because of our vulnerability.
China has openly stated they
are weaponizing everything
Western civilization
was built on--
energy and information.
And 5G is a perfect example.
If you don't think they
will act in a way that
steals our ideas
and our technology,
duplicates it, and then
dominates the marketplace,
take a look at 5G.
Nobody 20 years ago
would have ever believed
that America would not
have an answer to 5G when
China rolled it out.
Why didn't we have it?
Well, it's pretty easy.
China invited companies like
Lucent Technology, Motorola,
Nortel, into China
with a nice package
of benefits at the cost of
proprietary information,
intellectual property.
And they built Huawei out
of the bankrupt carcasses
of those three companies.
They stole the technology,
they duplicated it,
and then they dominated the
marketplace in an unfair way.
Unfair perfect example,
Vietnam in 2006.
They were bidding
for companies to come
build their telecommunication
infrastructure.
And so all these companies that
were world class global leaders
in telecommunications put out
their bids, competitive bids.
Huawei's bid, as a
young company being
grown by the Communist Party?
Zero dollars.
They built it for free.
How do you compete with that?
The same thing is happening with
the space industry right now.
If you're a German
that wants a satellite,
China will give
it to you for free
if you buy their satellite,
and they'll give you
the launch for 90% discount.
Far below what the
market can bear.
Because they can funnel
their political focus,
their military focus,
and their financial focus
into a vision and a
plan that does not
suffer from the blessing
of our republic,
where parties come and
go, programs get crushed,
they come back, and you can't
plan one year to the other,
or some years you can't plan
it all with a continuing
resolution, where you
can't do anything new.
And you don't have
any money to do it.
This is the difference
in strategy.
A strategy of speed to get to
this new continent of wealth
called the Moon and asteroids
and a cislunar economy,
to bring power to whatever
country dominates that economy.
It's like America
is a race car that
has been winning races for
70 years since World War II.
We're going 90 miles
an hour, and we've
done it that way
since World War II.
It's our entire mindset, our
entire lives the same way.
China is in a car
right behind us.
The car isn't as good, but
it's going 120 miles an hour.
We can say today, we
are dominant in space.
But the trend lines is
what you have to look at.
And they will pass us
in the next few years
if we do not do something.
And they will win this race, and
then they will put roadblocks
up to space.
Because once you get the
ultimate high ground,
that strategic high
ground, it's curtains
for anybody trying to get to
that high ground behind them.
Because they can apply power,
maneuver, and communication
at infinitesimally
lower price points.
And ultimately,
everything is economic.
If you can do something
cheaper than I can do it,
you will eventually beat me.
And all national security
comes from economies.
So speed is essential.
So we are building
brilliant satellites.
We are building
brilliant commands.
But we will be like taking
a glorified knife to a tank
fight, or the perfect single
action rifle to a machine gun
fight.
Because of this strategy is
not fighting China's strategy,
and we are stuck in our
mindset of the last 70 years
and what space has done so far.
This is not a military race,
this is an economic race.
And if you do not have a
guardian force to bring
rule of law and predictability,
no venture capitalists
will know how to
make risk decisions.
No company will
be able to invest.
And those that do will have
their hard work stolen away,
because the rule of law is not
codified by a guardian force.
The good news is, there are
more societies on planet Earth
that share our values as
an American society, that
will work with us to do this.
But right now, we're paralyzed.
Look at what's happening
in our government.
Yes, argument is good,
but we are paralyzed.
This National Defense
Authorization Act is at risk.
And even though
this president was
able to get a space force into
the dialogue, when he first
said it, the bureaucracy
howled with resistance.
And only after a year
and a half of hard work
are they now on board.
Just an example of the
resistance to the status quo,
wanting the status quo
to stay what it is.
But it's ironic, because it
reminds me of a story in 1400
that is an example that there's
nothing new under the sun
and history may not repeat
itself, but it sure does rhyme.
That old saying that
is clever but true.
In 1400, China had a two
party system, Ming dynasty.
The party in power saw this
thing called a navy and said,
that is powerful,
because that navy fleet
will mean that the ocean is
not a barrier, but rather
a highway to new marketplaces.
And they built the biggest
navy on planet Earth.
They would have been
the England of 1400
had they finished the job.
But the bickering of
politics, when the new party
came into power, they
burned every ship
to the ground in spite,
because the other party's idea
was the idea for a
navy, and not theirs.
That began a 600 year journey
to the century of humiliation.
And I'm here to tell you,
I read every document
that comes out of China.
I read every speech by every
senior policy official.
And I will tell you, they
talk about this story.
And that the Middle
Kingdom is back,
and America is in
its crosshairs.
And space is the navy for
the 21st century economy,
a networked economy
that will dominate
any linear terrestrial economy
in the four engines of growth
and dominance that
change world power--
transportation, information,
energy, and manufacturing.
And they are building
that infrastructure,
they are unapologetic
about it, and they
plan on declaring victory as the
dominant world power in space
at the 100 year
anniversary, 2049.
And in the next 10 years,
their energy and space
with nuclear and
solar power that
can be beamed to
the earth for good
and for bad, their ability
to control gateways of 5G
using space, quantum, artificial
intelligence, supercomputing,
to be able to shape the
perception of the world
and to tell any story
and to lie about America
or anybody else that is
counter to their purpose.
And you see how our
interdependency as a world
plays out when China
can lie about America
to all global markets, and
how that affects our economy
and our stock market.
Ultimately, it is
the manifestation
of a long, patient plan to
dominate information and energy
as weapons against the West,
so China's Middle Kingdom
can come back.
This is why we
need a space force.
This is why it needs to be now.
Because if we fumble the
football politically this year,
it'll be two years before we
get another National Defense
Authorization Act that will
give this the chance to survive.
And that's two years of money
in the bank at compound interest
for China, who's
furiously swimming away
to that continent
of Africa as we're
sitting on the beaches of Miami,
admiring the tide and our buoys
and lighthouses that can
see exactly what's going
on the shoreline in our orbit.
Why do we need a space force?
Because it's an
economic competition
for the values of the future.
When do we need it?
Now.
What does it need to do?
It doesn't have to have
war fighting capability.
It has to be able to defend
the economy of space.
A Coast Guard, a Merchant
Marine for space.
Because the national security
muscles and capabilities
will flow easily once
we tap into the profits
of those marketplaces.
Just like we have a
strong navy, because we
have a strong shipbuilding
industry, and a strong Merchant
Marine, and just because
we have a strong Air Force.
Because the aerospace
industry is our largest export
as a nation.
This is what long term strategy
and economic power look like,
and this is what we need.
And the scientists,
engineers, historians,
and strategists of our age have
brought this to our government.
The government has said, do it.
And now Congress is
asking the question,
why do we need to spend
money on a space force?
It would be like Teddy Roosevelt
getting pushback saying,
why do we need a Panama Canal?
Why do we need an Eisenhower
interstate system?
It's for commerce.
The power of the perpetuation
of the American dream
and the American values.
You are at a pivotal point.
The American people
don't know this story.
Congress doesn't even know
this story adequately,
except for a few.
And if we don't
get this story out,
your grandchildren will
probably be speaking Chinese.
That's not a bad language,
because the Chinese people
are beautiful people.
But their Communist Party will
murder the future generations
of free-loving people.
Liberty can be snuffed
out if we are not
mindful of the
power of technology
and the trap of a mindset
that clings to the status quo,
instead of allowing
our engineers
and our inventors
and our marketplaces
build a new future
with new paradigms
to dominate the marketplaces
of the 21st century.
Thank you for your
time and for listening,
and I look forward
to your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
See, that speech you wrote
was awesome, Michael.
MICHAEL ANTON: My question
is rhetorical, which is we've
seen a lot of news lately
about career officers, Foreign
Service officers, so-called
deep staters in the National
Security Council.
I have my misgivings about that.
But then I ask, if we're
going to have them,
why can't we have this guy?
OK, questions and there are
microphones roving around.
So please wait until you are
handed a mic before you ask.
STEVEN QUAST: So
the audience can
you hear the question
and people online.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Pardon me.
Could you describe
the nature of--
this August, the SAP
level almost immediately.
But for everybody's
edification, could you
describe our offensive
and defensive capabilities
in space versus those that our
adversaries currently have,
and what they will have
in the very near future?
STEVEN QUAST: OK, so
everybody heard that question.
I will tell you that whether
you're an Army officer,
a Naval officer or
an Air Force officer
or a Coast Guard officer, a
Marine officer, doesn't matter.
There is one truth
about a new domain.
If you want to dominate it and
you want to bring rule of law,
you have to be able
to maneuver more
aggressively and at
cheaper price points
than your competition.
You have to be
able to communicate
more ubiquitously
and more resiliently
than your competition.
And you have to be able
to bring power to bear,
whether that's kinetic
power, informational power,
non-kinetic power.
You have to be able to
bring power to bear,
and you have to do all of those
three things cheaper and faster
than your competition.
And you have to be able to deny
your competition those three
things.
China is feverishly working
on those three components
to be applied outside
of the gravity well.
That's beyond the orbits into
the moon and the cislunar
space, using the sun as
their source of energy that
is perpetual and can be beamed
to any place in that ecosystem.
They are literally
building the coal stations
equivalent to the ones
we built in the Pacific
when Teddy Roosevelt built the
great white fleet with iron
ships instead of wooden ships.
In fact, that story
is another one.
The wooden shipbuilders
and the sail builders
did not want to let
go of the wooden ship.
It was better than these
stinky old iron ships.
That was another journey
of a new paradigm that
had to crush an old paradigm.
And it was hard and long.
So I will tell you this.
Everything I've said
is in the open press.
But much of it has to be
translated from Mandarin.
And that's another
problem our journalists
and our American public have an
understanding what's going on.
But I will tell you this, 33
years of studying technology,
the Chinese, culture,
history, human nature,
China is feverishly
developing capability
to dominate those three areas in
cislunar space, and we are not.
We are perfecting orbital
mechanics, the shore line work,
precision, quality, brilliant
capability and equipment,
but irrelevant to China.
They can maneuver
outside the gravity
well, around the
backside of the moon.
And there is nothing
we can do if we are not
dominant in that
geography as well.
So that's why the Space Force is
so urgent, because China's got
a head start.
That car, right on our bumper,
going 120 miles an hour,
it won't be better
than what we'll build,
because we have an open
market free economy.
Ideas flourish.
But China steals them so fast,
duplicates them so rapidly,
floods a market so insidiously,
that even the brilliant idea
like what Tesla did
with their battery
that China stole and duplicated,
even a brilliant idea
like that, we're
behind the power curve.
5G.
We have no answer, because China
took all our stuff, built it,
flooded the market.
And now if you're a company
that doesn't have 5G,
you can't compete because speed
is life in the 21st century.
And we don't have an answer.
Germany wants it.
We would love as an American
country to give them some 5G
with the values of
America behind it.
But they only have one
option, and that's China.
Yeah.
I'll let you decide who goes.
MICHAEL ANTON: OK.
Right there.
Yeah.
STEVEN QUAST: Sorry, she is much
better looking than you are.
That's all I got to say.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for your speech.
I'm also one of the
WHIP students here.
And my question is, you've
talked a lot about the two
competing paradigms, how there's
the old one and the new one.
And the famous scientific
philosopher Thomas Kuhn often
spoke about how
these paradigms are
incommensurable to
each other, meaning
that if you're in
one paradigm, you
can't understand what someone's
saying from another paradigm.
How do you propose
that we bridge that gap
to bring people from the
old way of viewing things
into the new way in a
manner that's effective,
and that helps us spread
our values around the world?
STEVEN QUAST: That's
a great question,
and this is something that
I'm so glad you asked,
because history gives us all
the answers to this question.
And one of the reasons why I
was fortunate enough to see this
is because I grew up in a
different world paradigm.
I was raised in a tribe, I
didn't have to go to school.
Which explains a
lot, by the way,
still can't write
or spell very well.
And then coming to a
different world paradigm
at a fragile young
age allowed me
to see how devastating
the communication
gap can be between paradigms.
And we as civilizations
build a paradigm like energy,
let's say, the electricity
that we have delivered.
And we squirrel away at
inventing and innovating
within that paradigm, and
nobody looks outside to say,
hey, is there a different
economic curve here
we can jump to?
But there are enough
people in our society
that know how to
jump to that curve.
Elon Musk, Jeff Bezos,
Richard Branson.
God rest his soul, Paul Allen.
Luckily they have the money
to actually do something,
but they were rebels,
they were mavericks.
They were ridiculed
until they proved it.
So this is this played out with
Franklin Delano Roosevelt. When
we saw that Germany
was pursuing the bomb,
and we knew that if they
got that bomb first,
it was intuitive that
we had to be fast,
FDR did not turn to the
bureaucracy of the Army
and say, build me
a bomb, because he
knew the status quo and the
bureaucratic organizations
never can jump out
of their paradigm.
The pig does not
slaughter itself, OK?
You have to get outsiders.
That's why Congress and
the Executive Branch
have always been the ones that
have changed the military, not
inside.
So what FDR did is he
found the right leader.
And that was Oppenheimer.
Eisenhower did the same thing.
As the Soviet Union was
rearing its ugly head,
and the army was suggesting
putting a million soldiers
with bayonets affixed in the
fold, the gap of Germany,
Eisenhower said no.
Because one tactical nuke will
kill all my sons and daughters,
and I can't afford it.
And he turned to two
innovators, General Shriver
and Admiral Rickover.
And he said, build me a nuclear
triad so we can have a balance.
Now, mutually
assured destruction
is no happy way of
going through life.
But it was a way
of having a bulwark
against this
devastating technology.
The same is true today.
We need a Manhattan
type project in order
to develop this properly.
Because the price
of entry to space
is so high that
only billionaires
that are willing to pour
their own money into it
are making any progress.
But they are hounded and
blocked at every turn.
Elon Musk, for example,
has to pay the Air Force
$13 million every time he
launches from Vandenberg Air
Force Base for no good reason.
Just risk aversion
in a bureaucracy.
And when everything
goes perfect,
he doesn't get that money back.
They use it for their own
coffers and their own thing.
That's the cover your butt
kind of mentality that happens
in a bureaucracy that cannot
jump outside of the paradigm.
There's no other way.
Turning to the government or
the bureaucracy to do this
will not work.
But an Executive
Branch or a Congress
that's willing to pick the
right leader that understands
that technology, the history,
the culture, the paradigm,
and picks the right
engineers and scientists,
they'll build it.
Because there's nothing more
powerful than the American free
enterprise that welcomes
diversity of thought
and will try things and fail.
And no Communist Party is going
to shoot them if they fail.
If they fail for the right
reasons, they are promoted.
If they fail for the wrong
reasons, you coach them,
and if they fail three
times, you fire them.
For example, General
Shriver, as he
was building the missile
fields of our nuclear triad,
the first 13 rockets blew up.
Only Eisenhower was
able to protect him
from the hounds of Congress
and the Air Force that
hated him, that wanted
him out, that felt
that his work was coming at
the cost of the man bomber.
History is playing out again.
Did that answer your question?
Who's next?
MICHAEL ANTON: You.
Go ahead.
STEVEN QUAST: Your
mic is coming.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Jacob
Rich from Reason Foundation.
And I'm curious.
So you said that
China's already started
building destroyers and other
military vessels for space.
And I'm just curious,
should we steal
their intellectual
property to catch up?
STEVEN QUAST: Well,
I will tell you
that this is the insidious
nature of strategy
versus equipment.
OK?
So China is building nuclear
thermal power propulsion
capabilities to be able
to maneuver in space.
We know how to do that,
and we can do it better.
Their stuff is not good.
Now, 5G is good.
The 5G technology is good,
because it's our stuff.
But the stuff they're
building is not
better than what we can build.
It's not about equipment.
It's not about
stealing our ideas,
because their ideas
are inferior to ours.
It's the fact that they're
building an entire method
of being able to have a blanket
of power over America in space
that can bring directed energy
to paralyze our power grids,
paralyze our cars, paralyze our
military, disrupt our markets.
They're doing it on a social
level with the Confucius
Centers and a narrative.
The small space
companies, for example, I
could bring in the CEOs of
the small space companies,
and here's what's
happening to them.
There will be somebody that
will come up to them and say,
I will give you
a billion dollars
if you put me on your board.
And when they
follow the money, it
was China that
gave him the money,
gave an American that
money and said, here's
a billion dollars for free.
Go and get on the boards
of these companies,
and your only price
tag is to bring
me the intellectual property
and the proprietary information.
And so it's hard.
A company will come to
me and say, what do I do?
And I'll say, do
not take the money,
because you will sell your soul.
This is where the
government needs to help.
The government
needs to help make
sure there is an even
playing field economically,
or all these fragile
new space companies
will never build an
industrial base equivalent
to the aerospace industry or
the shipbuilding industry that
have made our nation
free and strong
for the last hundred years.
And it will die in the crib.
The Space Force
and everything we
need to do to protect this
economy will die in the crib,
and China will own the
information, the gateways,
the technologies that flood
all the other countries
of the world.
Even our friends like
Germany and England
have 5G, and are getting
more and more of it.
Our nuclear power plants
have 5G technology in them.
And those are all riddled
with back doors and spyware
that can see everything
we're doing as a nation.
We know it.
This is like a slow growing
vine around the spinal cord
of America,
insidiously and slowly,
because that is the mindset
of the Chinese strategy.
It is not to fight.
They don't want to fight.
They want to dominate the
economic prowess of America
over 100 years, and we
go out with a whimper.
MICHAEL ANTON: Over here.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: So you
mention the fact
that the Executive
and the Congress
affect the military
to the same respect.
Do you think changing the
public's mind will be helpful
as well?
STEVEN QUAST: That's a
great question, and yes.
There are two groups
of people that do not
understand what's going on--
the American people
and Congress.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
STEVEN QUAST: And again, you
know I retired in September.
And I have been spending
my every waking hour
helping Congress understand
what's going on here.
Because it's essentially the
same as China ignoring the Navy
and regretting it
600 years later when
their civilization rotted
from within because
of external players that
stole away their values.
Or England, that lost an
entire generation of men
before they realized what the
competition was really about.
It wasn't about Napoleonic
soldiers shoulder
to shoulder on a parade
field with courage.
It was about the
machine gun and gas.
And it killed them all.
Deep regret.
But they went into
it enthusiastic.
Read the literature
of the time, 1914.
They couldn't wait to go die.
They just didn't know
they were going to die.
They thought courage
would save them.
They underestimated the
power of technology.
We're doing the same right now.
But the enemy is
not as aggressive.
China is passive.
China is silent.
China is insidious.
China has a 100 year plan.
One step at a time, a slow
growing vine that slowly
paralyzes the competition.
So the American
people need to know.
They do not know.
Help me get it to them.
Congress doesn't fully
know, and the reason
I know that is not only because
I've been talking to them,
some do, but they're still
asking this question.
Why do we need a Space Force?
It's a waste of money.
We've got NASA.
That would be like sending
the wagon trains out west
with no cavalry.
MICHAEL ANTON: OK.
STEVEN QUAST: See
I said something
that inspired you
to ask a question,
because you popped up.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thanks for coming.
I want to talk about the balance
of power in the Asia-Pacific.
I think Japan's
sure to go nuclear.
They won't maybe in 5
years, maybe 10 years.
That's going to offset
the Chinese advancing.
That's what I think.
STEVEN QUAST: OK, well
let me talk to that,
because I disagree
fundamentally with that premise.
And it's not that that wouldn't
necessarily have a short term
benefit of deterrence.
But the power of space does
something really important
here.
And this is really
where I'm going to end.
But I'll just do a
little slice of this,
and then I'll end
with the later part.
And that is a vision.
The power of space can
do what Reagan was doing,
and the physics just
didn't quite close.
Brilliant Pebbles
was the program
to put a space base layer
that could see and kill
any missile launched
the moment we knew
was launched in a
direction that was
nefarious to American values.
And it could be shot
down before it even
left the geographic
boundaries of whichever
place it was launched.
You can build that off a
shelf today, and we have not,
and China is.
So Japan going nuclear, no.
What we could do if we
as an American society
decided to invest in the
infrastructure of space
for information
for all Americans.
Reliable energy.
Information is
protected, by the way,
because it's not the internet.
You can build gateways that
design trust into it, where
every American can have
their data without having
to sacrifice their
civil liberties.
Energy that can be provided
to anybody on planet Earth
without strings
attached like they
do with the Uyghurs and
Hong Kong and any individual
where they hold their parents
hostage if they don't behave
properly, or they don't get
to go to the right schools,
or they don't get to buy
the food that's good.
Space can make ICBMs,
intercontinental ballistic
missiles, literally
antiques of past wars.
And then I'll end
with the other vision.
But that's one vision.
You can't get rid
of nuclear weapons,
because you can
always deliver them
in a backpack or
some other means.
But you can deliver
the capability
to dominate marketplaces
economically.
And you can literally
design a new world order
that does not have so
much violence built
into our deterrence model.
Where if a civilization
is threatening our values,
we can deter them without
violence in ways they cannot
compete with.
So I'd rather not go the
route of arming more people
with more nuclear weapons.
We don't have to go
down that paradigm.
That's getting trapped in
the paradigm of the past.
I want to move to a new paradigm
where China can't follow,
and most other countries on
planet Earth cannot follow
either, but all of our
friends will go with us.
And the Japanese
are part of that.
There's a very inquisitive
question right here,
and that I'm dying to hear.
AUDIENCE: We'll get to him.
STEVEN QUAST: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Have we an idea of
the cost of this initiative?
STEVEN QUAST: Yeah, so the
cost of the initiative--
AUDIENCE: I'm sure it
will be in phases, but--
STEVEN QUAST: Right.
So cost is always the first
question, and bureaucracy.
Because right now,
what has happened
is our country has turned
to our military and said,
build a Space Force.
And I guarantee you, it'll be
bureaucratic, it'll be big,
it'll be expensive, and
it won't get the job done.
That's the nature of the
bureaucracy and the government.
Now, it will maybe
succeed in 50 years.
But we don't have that
luxury, because our pacing has
to be predicated on our
competition, not on the fact
that we have been unilaterally
dominant economically
for the last 70 years,
and we could do anything
at any pace we wanted and
we didn't have to care
because nobody was competing.
So here we are sitting on the
shores of Miami Beach with
our piña colada.
And we are like,
oh, Space Force.
Eh, eh, how much is
it going to cost?
I will tell you.
You don't build
the Space Force out
of the coffers of
the taxpayers' money.
We built an automobile
industry because it
was so useful to people,
the marketplace built it.
The computer industry,
the aerospace industry.
Space is going to be so
useful to all humanity.
Trillion dollar markets in
telecommunication, trillion
dollar markets in
transportation.
Speed is life, speed is money.
How many people
are willing to get
from here to Singapore in 39
minutes instead of 39 hours?
No, not quite that far.
So I am here to tell you
that, if this is done right,
the strategy is
to build the space
force with the profits of the
marketplaces that you dominate.
And you've got partners
in civil society.
Elon Musk, Jeff Bezos.
Elon Musk is going to dominate
transportation and information
with his starship and his
13,000 satellites for Wi-Fi
from space.
We already have
companies that are
going to have texting
from space next year.
In fact, their test
satellite is already up.
And I don't need a
cell tower to text.
So this is the trick
of free markets.
You build it with the
profits of the marketplace
if you design it right.
That's why all national security
is foundationally economic.
Hopefully private industry.
Absolutely, those are
the titans of innovation.
They aren't bogged down by
a culture of risk aversion
that bakes into our
government and our military.
And they're willing
to take risk.
And those are the only ways
of competing and winning
in a real race.
Risk and the
willingness to fail.
MICHAEL ANTON: All right.
This will be the last
one, I'll let you--
STEVEN QUAST: I'd like
this young lady right here
to say a word.
Well, I do too.
[LAUGHS] Here, there's a mic.
And if it's not a
good question, I'll
answer the question
I want to answer.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: My question
is, what can we
do to spread this information?
Because I have--
this is not new.
We get tidbits of this
through the news media.
But nothing to the extent that
you have explained it tonight.
This is critical to the
future of our country.
This is it.
STEVEN QUAST: This is where
an educated electorate
is so key to our Constitution
that our Founding Fathers wrote
about.
And do not underestimate
the power of the network.
One node touching
three other nodes
that touched three other nodes.
Is the sage old story of a young
man who really did something
brilliant for the king,
and the king said, well,
I don't have a lot of money,
but what can I do to repay you?
And the man said,
just give me one grain
of rice on this chessboard
on this first square.
And on the second
square give me two.
And keep doubling it for
every piece of the chessboard.
Now, many of you
probably know this story.
By the time you have gotten
to the end of the chessboard
squares, how much
rice do you have?
AUDIENCE: A lot.
STEVEN QUAST: OK, so the entire
planet Earth, six feet high.
That's the power of the network.
And it's interesting
that we end on a network.
Because there's another
important point about space.
So to answer your
question specifically,
is tell your friends.
And start reading.
It is out there.
It's just hard to find.
And it's out there, but
just recently in this way,
because I couldn't write
about this in the Air Force.
People do not want to
scare the American people.
And I don't want to
scare them either.
But for God's sakes, our
future is at stake here.
We are victims to a strategy
we don't even recognize.
And as a person who grew up in
a different cultural paradigm
that can see this clearly, and
has studied this for 33 years,
I am here to tell
you, it is imminent.
And the more we can be in the
dark, the happier China is.
Because then the coup
de grace is done,
and it is fait accompli.
And there's nothing
we can do about it.
And now I believe that America
is so energetic intellectually
and so courageous
that eventually we
will fight our way back.
But the English haven't
even fought their way
back from World War I. So
the next hundred years,
the values that will rule
the next hundred years
will be defined by this next 10
years and who dominates space.
So here is the vision, though.
This is why I started by saying,
this is such a happy story.
You might think, oh my God,
you know, doom and gloom.
No.
Here is a story.
Every technology, even though
people can use technology
for evil, every technology has
uplifted the human condition
over time.
If you take a look
at the human race,
there are a higher
percentage of human beings
that have energy, water,
security, food, than ever
before on planet Earth, ever.
Now, there's more people, so
there's more people in poverty
than ever before.
But the ratio is moving
in a good direction.
It's because there are more
people that love their children
and respect other
people than there
are evil people like
Stalin and Lenin
and Mao, who would
kill them for power.
And this Constitution,
I believe,
is such a unique and
ordained document
that if we fumble the ball now,
because we don't pay attention
to technology, and
how it can change
world power, shame on us.
But here's the vision.
The vision is with
a new paradigm
that space could bring us, if
we built this infrastructure,
if we had the vision
to build the Panama
Canal of our age, the
infrastructure of space,
we can bring clean
and abundant energy
affordable to every
person on planet Earth
with no power lines, no
power plants required.
Central Africa, where I grew up.
That tribe could have
information and energy
right now.
We have machines that can
bring water out of the air
without energy from space,
where you could just give them
a piece of technology
and they can
have clean water with
no pipes, no aquifers,
no rivers required.
You can bring
trusted information
to any person on planet
Earth where they do not
have to live with a
scourge of an internet that
was designed to be open
and free, no security.
Yet we are trapped in that
paradigm, spending ourselves
into oblivion, into bankruptcy,
trying to make something secure
that was never
designed to be secure.
We could bring
secure, trusted data
to every human being
on planet Earth,
underpinned by American values
and the American Constitution.
We could bring medical healing
because of research facilities
in space that benefit from
zero gravity and a vacuum
that we can never do in
the terrestrial realm
without great cost and energy.
The server farms in America
that are growing exponentially,
that are sucking
energy beyond belief,
could be put into space
and no energy required
because it's freezing up there.
And the ability to
communicate and compute.
The faster we can move
to independent operations
in space, the more secure we
will be, the more differential
power we'll have as an
economy and as a civilization
to defend against terrorism and
the despots of Communism that
are rearing their
ugly head and trying
to come after
Western civilization
and attacking the two
foundational weaknesses
we have built our
entire prosperity on--
energy and information.
And both of them are at
risk, and both of them
are unaffordable to fix.
So don't struggle.
We're struggling to get a
secure grid, a resilient grid.
We're struggling to get secure
data and resilient data.
Stop struggling.
Let our inventors
and our innovators
design a new paradigm to
uplift the human condition
and have America underwrite it.
And America will be
the beneficiaries
to the amount of trillions
of dollars of profit
to perpetuate those
business cases
to deliver every human
being on planet Earth
prosperity and the blessing
that we respect them no matter
who they are, no matter
what they believe,
as long as they respect us.
That's the vision,
that's the joy.
Not the negative stuff.
The negative stuff is only if
good men and women do nothing.
Then the negative
stuff happens and we
return to our
academicians and say,
like they did to Dr.
Fisher in England,
why did we lose a
generation of men?
A lack of vision,
a lack of strategy.
Not equipment, their
equipment was brilliant.
But it wasn't a
machine gun or gas.
And they didn't
even think about it.
We're too courageous for that.
We'll be just fine, just like we
have been for the last hundred
years.
And that's what
you hear today is
you hear, we don't need
a separate Space Force,
because we want to integrate
it into the Joint Force,
in the Army, in the
terrestrial fight.
That's our purpose.
Not even thinking
beyond the orbits
into cislunar space and
the trillion dollar markets
that will come from that.
We are at a point
in civilization
where for the first
time in human history,
we can reach to the
heavens, a gift God
has given us, for our resources,
our energy, and our information
in a way that will never
have to scar the earth again
for all those things we need.
We need resources
to feed our families
and shelter our people.
We need the ability to
defend those things.
We need the sense
of belonging that
comes with loving our
families and our tribes.
And we need to understand
what's going on around us.
Those are the only
four things we need.
Resources, defending
the resources, a sense
of belonging and understanding.
Space can give us that.
But the journey of
1,000 miles to the cost
and the time, people say
is 100 years too soon.
It's too expensive.
A journey of 1,000 miles
starts with the first step.
And we haven't even
taken the first step.
And if we don't get a National
Defense Authorization Act,
we will be giving
our competition that
has taken tremendous
leaps into this future two
years of compound interest
in the bank ahead of us.
That 120 mile an hour
car and our bumper
will be two miles
in front of us.
And they'll put
up those barriers.
They'll throw out those
tacks onto the road
so our tires deflate.
We may have a better car,
but without good tires,
you aren't going anywhere.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
STEVEN QUAST: That's
what I'm talking about.
MICHAEL ANTON: All right.
STEVEN QUAST: Thank you.
MICHAEL ANTON: Thank you, and
thank you everyone for coming.
[APPLAUSE]